go live doing it
to live crew we live
alive and well we are live who's got us
who got us on their eardrum tell me if
you can hear us
can you hear me this is gonna be the
most experimental live stream we've done
having john here so he can do all the
controls oh
this is a yeah we can cannot have that
playing in my ear
can they not hear us i'm not says we're
live
it should be
hello hi i can't oh they can hear us now
my god
oh he's got a little bit of lag that's
us that's us for you
always got a little bit of lag there
it's like when we say we're gonna arrive
at the party at a certain time we're
always gonna be late that's how we go
well you know we had some retooling to
do uh
since this live stream is a little
different than normal we had some
technical uh tweaking to do
yo big boy trent erica tuesday anissa
montezer alpho spangler xs trip coach
crystal so many people in the chat right
now appreciate y'all being here it's
gonna be a fun one this is gonna be very
experimental um
we know other people have done live
streams kind of like this before
and today i put it all in john's hands
to figure out all the technical [ __ ]
so if this goes well thank john the envy
this doesn't go well
blame john i mean i'm still a little a
little sour grapes right now about this
chat box screwing up the entire like
template
like we had a great time a whole new
template
and then just the chat wouldn't scroll
live and i was
ah but it's okay we will endure all
right if this is your first time here
thank you so much for being here so yeah
what we're gonna do today and then
we did put a mention in here i guess
i'll have to remind every couple minutes
or something like that not every couple
minutes i'd be obnoxious
uh so we want to do live reactions and
then what we'll do today too
is um you know it's like i appreciate
you guys who are sending in the super
chats already we also have stream labs
as well
and uh we don't really have anything in
mind
there was a couple that i've had in mind
of what to check out i i kind of wanted
to check out the opening scene to
umbrella academy season two
um we so we wanna there's there's a lot
to do happy birthday to my brother jaby
coway by
the way happy co-a and i said nah i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna
go see my brother i'm gonna do a live
stream now i'm seeing him tomorrow
that's what he wanted
and then um and then yeah so then uh
what we're trying to
keep it at is no music videos and no
amazon videos in anime
because we because we've talked to one
too many people who've said that they've
got on their videos and
our us included they get blocked
worldwide in the middle of a stream
so we don't want to like start reacting
to something and then youtube goes
shut it down yeah that would be the most
annoying part
yeah we're in uh we're in different
seats and by the way for people who are
asking i am planning on
reacting to umbrella academy season
two right now so john tell them about
your day
while i pull up the first video i would
like us to react to we will definitely
actually you know what we got we already
got a super chat here
from anissa who's asking us to check out
the words on the bathroom walls movie
trailer so
right so what should how should we do
this should i be like
john click the click the super chat so
people see
yeah i guess so so okay let's go ahead
go words on the bathroom walls
movie trailer all right all right john
while you download it
and we'll get this going very
experimental
um all right so where are we at in this
chat right now do reactions to umbrella
academy seasons yeah we switch seats
because all like the mouse pad stuff is
over here and john is more tech savvy
especially when it comes to the live
streams
just made a lot more sense to keep it
this way all right he's downloading the
trailer for you anissa
oh look out now what the hell is words
on bathroom walls
we are about to find out yeah
and we could do trailers revisited too
carter if there's an old one that you
want us to talk about
it's sure true that oh it's gonna be fun
live reactions i've been wanting to do
this for so long
well if you're john i hope you figured
this out hey you want to see if we if we
have
yeah let's do it well here we go words
on bathroom wall movie trailer let's do
this
hmm honey it's so good yeah mm-hmm have
a good day
me too when you're finished with the
questions
please
ow
and that's when we found out i have
schizophrenia
a chronic mental disorder allowing for
visual and auditory hallucinations
abnormal yeah it's kind of kind of a
camera monohand voice some people just
hear voices
good morning but i see mine more awesome
i had to switch schools there's a
straight jacket freak
my mom is on this quest for a cure oh
wow
but nothing works just give it time this
could potentially be
very insensitive if not handled properly
yeah
i'm maya i'm madam i came over here to
intimidate you
but something tells me you're homeless
if you need anything let me know
oh for the first time in forever i felt
normal
what's with the cookbooks i'm sort of
studying to be a chef
sort of where are you what don't look at
me
look at her you have a problem with that
oh
fast exactly what comes to me well it's
best to say exactly what you mean or
nothing at all
unrelenting honesty you know
whoa it's so weird you know when i first
met you i thought
maybe he's just awkward and unsocialized
but that's not it there's something else
i don't know what to say to that i'll
crack you petrucelli last night
when you finally called me i know that
you must be scared
and that it's lonely in your head
when you're a cancer kid people are so
eager to grant any wish you have
but when you have schizophrenia people
treat you differently
is that why you didn't tell me because
you thought that i was going to leave
i've seen a lot of this movie i know
recovering most of this movie right now
is that andy garcia everyone's flawed
but admitting our flaws
gives us the opportunity the face that
it is
i shouldn't
i can't put you through that what makes
you think you get to make them
let people discover all your dark places
inside because those are the people that
can show you what's real darth maul
[Music]
words on bathroom walls
look e there that was such a unique
trailer
it was that was such a unique trailer
that we just watched
did you guys hear that we want to make
sure you guys could hear that uh the
words on the bathroom walls
okay um all right so we got to make sure
we keep our reviews of these things
short today so we don't run over here
these are going to be like stardust
i mean it's just like a wide random
array of all kinds of indie dramedy
movies but with this
schizophrenic twist angle on it that has
a visually stunning appeal to it but
it's also really just a rom-com at its
heart
yeah and um some of it looks like cliche
to a cernix
i mean undoubtedly like i'm like yeah
that looks like one of those young adult
kind of movies right there
but i love the visual element to it and
the main guy looks good
and the uh the romance looks fairly
believable
yeah i mean i've not i've kind of
wondering
i feel like you get a little insensitive
about such a subject but i also feel
like they've done
eloquently it could be something rather
beautiful yeah it makes me i mean
the main thing i would wonder is just if
anybody who is actually
had schizophrenia or or you know has
somebody
in their life with you know has
experienced it firsthand i guess that is
the thing i would
want to be present in the writing or the
direction or something
uh because that's my main worry is just
you know i think
it's uh there's a lot you can do with
visual metaphors
and various mental states and yeah i
just wouldn't want it to be the kind of
thing where it makes schizophrenia look
like this crazy fantasy land in your
head
yeah uh you're just white for anyone
who's just tuning in we just watched the
trailer for words on bathroom walls
yeah and so that's why we're like uh
that's what we're talking about right
now but i do like the idea a lot and i
mean
i like the idea of more movies that
explore
more uh you know states and ailments
that
a lot of average people don't
necessarily have much experience or
understanding
of the trailer itself was a weird
journey yeah because at the first you're
like this is
a mystery movie oh no it's this movie
about schizophrenia touching
it's a romantic comedy it's a movie
about bullying it seems like it's
dealing with a lot of different things
at once yeah
i would like to hear somebody with
schizophrenia's reaction
to this i would like to know what they
think but it looks pretty cool to me
all right cool all right what'd you guys
think of that trailer heck yeah
what'd you guys think of it all right so
who's next out here who's next
what's uh oh another super chat from
anissa also i know you said no music
videos but this one is special
we're not doing music videos today only
because they're likely to get this
stream blocked while we're streaming
yes uh bradley loves you spin me around
big well thank you for the super chat
anissa we'll make sure to do it
will herons asking favorite genre of
music country rep
dad that's a thing careful there
that's real um oh favorite genre of
music
alternative rock i guess just for me
since no one's requested it yet i'm
gonna do this great i'm gonna do this
for me
what is i'm gonna pull up the umbrella
academy oh yeah
season two opening scene this will be
good because i i'm gonna start it right
after i
finish the boys tonight so don't worry
if you guys like
um you know uh send in like super chats
and stuff we will definitely get to them
you know what
we just take a long time because take a
look we're gonna watch right now
umbrella academy season two i
i'm planning my plan is to uh john
hasn't seen it yet so
my buddy aaron is going to react to it
with me
and do you want to set that up joe we're
doing this sure thing um
so my buddy aaron's going to react uh
with it
to and normally we put all our tv show
reactions up on youtube
i've talked with uh the head eric over
at blind wave and he was like no we
they went through a lot of struggles to
get umbrella academy season one
up on youtube um they like a lot of
blocked worldwide and had to keep
re-uploading it
so but you know i was like [ __ ] it let's
give it a shot this time
we're gonna put it up on we're gonna put
season two up on youtube to the best of
our abilities
the reaction highlights will be there
full length will be over at our patreon
where you can sync up with the time code
and such
so we're not doing it for you know like
the videos won't be monetized
but you guys should be able to see them
the goals try to get them up every other
day starting sunday that's the current
goal
anywho umbrella academy season two
opening scene i've seen a few people in
the chat already mention it
john pull it up yes and uh just real
quick we are also going to be checking
stream labs
uh for those of you who have asked here
we go umbrella academy i'm gonna start
watching
the show tomorrow i have yet to see the
opening scene
let's do this
[Music]
great spoiler for john here
sophia it's attack us
keep your head down
the hell did we do
[Music]
dude this is the opening scene
[Music]
[Applause]
this oh heard a rumor that i blew your
mind
dude it became a superhero team in 1983.
[Music]
wow
dude they all look so different
you can't save them if you're dead
[Music]
oh my god i'm so excited to start this
show
i may have seen season i saw season one
this month alone
i haven't even seen the season two
trailer wow that was the first
first thing i've seen in season two that
looks incredible
oh my goodness that looks incredible not
bad i wish i could go into it with you
john because you haven't seen it yet but
don't worry you won't
i think you'll still be like confused on
what's happening yeah you're confused
no context you're not gonna see what's
going on but man everyone looks so
different
everyone looks so different what the
[ __ ] did five do
all right guys i'm gonna be reacting to
it every day so as much as i'm going to
big [ __ ] trailer review or opening
scene review right now
just keep a lookout for the reactions
that we'll get start post hopefully
start posting on sunday
but man that was well worth it thank you
to everyone who was hitting us up in
this live stream being like you got to
check this out
all right who's next on the super chat
here will heron
already answered it we got that that's
right country rap is my favorite genre
of music
you know little nazix does con it's not
just nelly there you go
uh bernie alvarado is next uh thank you
thank you bernie alvarado have you any
any of you guys play kingdom hearts and
final fantasy
ex those are good games i played kingdom
hearts back in the day
i haven't played kingdom hearts i've
seen my girlfriend play kingdom hearts
she looks very happy when she's playing
definitely i suggest in the super chats
guys to request a trailer for something
too but appreciate your super chat
bernie and yeah final fantasy x my
girlfriend's playing 14. every one of
the video games as i've laid has been
like i've seen my girlfriend playing it
she's really liking the game so far do
boyfriend reviews where
you just do a girlfriend reviews does
but in reverse i should i'm almost done
with um i'm almost done with
uh spider-man jedi fall in order that's
next on the list spider-man jedi fallen
over i mean star wars jedi fall in order
um but thank you bernie alvarado and
then anissa's saying
john i like your shirt greg i like your
face oh
i guess one's a better compliment than
the other am i right yeah
thank you anisa you can always change
your shirt chase
gardner anissa you're so sweet just
talking to me earlier chase gardner
thanks buddy assassin's creed valhalla
evior's fate trailer johnny
download the bad boy okay eventually we
have to do this avengers war table thing
all right because it seems like that's
what the chat's really all about right
now
okay tell you what tell you what we'll
do the assassin's creed one to honor the
super chat
we gotta check stream labs and then uh
the war table stream i heard were in the
beginning of it
so we gotta check that out but it's 17
minutes long so i don't do we want to
watch the whole thing should we watch
the whole thing
i don't think we lose a team lose all
the viewers like what if not everyone's
interested in that i think
17 minutes might be a little a little
much but
we'll see we'll see we'll see we'll see
all right so we're going to check out
right now
chase gardner's request assassin's creed
valhalla
avior's fate trailer wish olivia was
here for this one
i know you want a rouster no she's doing
homework
oh goody all right a little bit of
readjustment when this pops up because
let's see if you guys are here
too hit that like button while you're at
it too we mean a hell of a lot
yeah all right let's see this
i can see your fate
oh i didn't even hear about this trailer
it flows
like a river like a river carved out
before you
i can see your desires taking you
far from your home to lands of
power of mystics
and legends t-bird
you are hiding something
i'm a badass
you walk with shadows what is it
you seek i see conquest
i see your enemies
everything
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
all right i gotta go to the axe throwing
reigns see all of it
blood and flame loyalty
and family betrayal
hunker there is a war within you
and glory will not be enough
i love all those visual opacity shots
that i keep doing
like with his brain at that closing shot
oh that looks great yeah and um good
call
and what was that i don't know the name
of the character who's talking to him
she provided all the mystery to it i
can't get over the fact of how
this feels nothing like assassin's creed
yeah this just keeps
every time i watch it anything for this
game i'm like
where's the all the motifs for
assassin's creed i'm so used to seeing
you know what i mean
you know you gotta reinvent yourself to
keep people
interested after like 50 iterations of
the game
but uh yeah i am a little and people in
the comments from the first video we
covered for this seem to be a little
taken aback by that
other than the fact that it does look
really cool
i mean adrian in the chat is saying all
the games are better than the movie
which is the one benefit to it even if
there's a faulty assassin's creed video
game
it's better than that movie that came
out with michael fossbender that's for
sure
i would love to to just know what what
got him on board for that
are you guys uh excited for this
assassin's creed valhalla game this is
the third trailer i've checked out for
it so far
and i mean it looks every time i watch
it it looks [ __ ] cool it's pretty
cold
it looks it looks really cool pretty
cool oh my god i could be a viking
yeah yeah but in terms of a viking game
i think what's great is like
there's something about being a viking
that seems to be really popular in
television right now
so i feel like for assassin's creed to
be diving into this territory with being
a viking
it was this a really smart business
decision on there and
especially with the popularity of the tv
show vikings yeah
absolutely although funny enough this
made me just watching this
it made me think of antoine fuqua's king
arthur movie
a little bit of how the like especially
with the ice and the norsemen and all
that stuff but
a little bit i love that thank you chase
gardner
sergio mendoza do a reaction on the
short halo infinite
trailers oh john you're gonna have to do
some research
you're gonna have to do some research
yeah the graphics do look pretty insane
on assassin's creed right now
okay okay okay what do we got what do we
got what do we got eight minute demo
we got a minute campaign gameplay
trailer
i watched the campaign trailer i i
actually filmed the reaction for the
campaign trailer and the mic wasn't on
now you know what would help is if you
guys
put like links in the in the live stream
or something like that so you know we
know for sure we're watching the right
one
yeah that you're hoping we actually
check out i was gonna say
let's let's go to the halo channel and
then i'll i'll i'll
i'll work my way wait a minute now i
watched a much shorter one
all right this game while we're looking
at the live stream right now
while we're looking at the live stream
right now would you prefer
if okay he's saying the short halo
infinite trailers which one's he talking
about well this one's a minute
one of that this gameplay trailer from
july 20 which halo trailer should we
watch
we will revisit this in a second this is
a weekend oh chat doesn't allow links
that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] youtube um
all right well we'll do the we'll how
about this
i think everyone's gonna keep asking us
about the avengers the wartime the war
table one
so we're gonna get the avengers war
table one and then we're gonna focus on
all the super chat ones
right afterwards okay so avengers july
war table
um now somebody said they'd cut it into
pieces
should we just take the full seventeener
uh go to
go to marvel go to marvel's channel uh
marvel entertainment yeah click on
marvel
we got this guys don't this is behind
the scenes also this is
experimental stream and uh getting some
calls to check the stream labs as well
um okay let's see videos
oh no [ __ ] that let's watch this natalie
cordova buckley
in a superhero workout video oh now that
is what y'all came here for
all right change of plans go back to ign
all right all right we're gonna watch
we're gearing up should we just do the
full july one
uh i mean we can or we could cut it up
into pieces we could react
to a few what everyone is saying is what
everyone is saying
is that we're in the beginning of it so
i feel like we should watch the first
few minutes
let's watch the first few minutes and if
we really
love it then we can keep going
[Laughter]
so yeah i'm gonna just hide this really
quick
check the streams over here uh
we will be ready oh man this is a big
video because it's loading for a long
time but
we're getting this going guys apologies
for any little delays here
okay oh wow we got some stream labs up
in this
bad boy [ __ ] you oh damn we gotta we
gotta get to it
all right all right how about this we
got to narrow this down and then we're
going to have a smooth stream from here
on out
what part of the avengers war table one
do you want us to check
out which one do you want us to check at
him we'll go do it right now
type away guys type away
watch until the hawkeye reveal all right
that's what we're gonna do john
what's gonna be at the very end it's
gonna be at the 15 minutes
17 minutes 10 seconds it's gonna be at
the very end
golly it's loaded in there here we go
we're gonna watch the war table stream
and then we're gonna catch up on all the
requests right afterwards
let's see what's in store
i know
i wonder if i can play
and you just watched square enix and
crystal dynamics avengers war table
stream
we actually got a lot of gameplay we got
a lot more information
we're coming up
but i also like that they are taking a
step beyond i don't know
hey here's uh modoc here's aim that's
exciting to me that's we're not just
fighting ultron again
dude this is crazy so each mission is
gonna be based on that certain avenger
there is a lot a lot to this game
customizing
them honoring the reactors that they
demonetized
you need a robust customization system
and i do think that that is what this
game is going for i'm in like this looks
awesome i want to play this i want to
get into this
it seemed the coolest across the world
was just the breath
of modes you could get into what the
[ __ ] i play more games than you they
like you talking
hey i when i was younger
what speaks to me is the amount they
took me where i'm just looking serious
as [ __ ] this [ __ ] just cropped on your
face
well at least you have the system you
can play it on let
i'm me i'm in
wow wow i get serious listening face
while john gets
dialogue in there i mean you know
welcome to the july marvel's avengers
war table first off a huge thank you to
everyone who joined our first marvel's
avengers 4 table last month
and extra thanks as well for telling us
what you like we should all copyright
claims
all the reactors yeah you can't use my
footage [ __ ] uh we're gonna
share that revenue we'll see you can
monetize it but we're gonna take the
money
we'll start with breaking down
everything you need to know about the
beta
then we'll share a glimpse at how our
game will expand after launch starting
with our first post launch here for
lunch and we'll have a few surprises
along the way
this is beta i mean all this is pretty
[ __ ] cool to be in this
it really is
there better be some glorious new [ __ ]
they show us
skip at it come on
harm
[Music]
abomination nice
yeah i want colson as an unlockable
character
i want to play as kobe smulders the beta
opens with the entire golden gate bridge
demo
dropping players into the middle of the
chain of events that led to the 8 a
disaster
right right this is 25 minutes of
gameplay and a great introduction to how
each hero plays and how combat and
traversal work
we built the golden gate bridge sequence
to be this roller coaster ride of an
experience
with huge set pieces tons of combat and
traversal
and a taskmaster boss battle it's also a
chance to try out
many of each of the heroes special
combos
heroics and specific moves yeah we know
all this come on yeah
from there it seems to open up just like
the full game does
all right giving you new single-player
hero missions and eventually
single-player or co-op war zones to
discover oh
yeah i like these night time battles
kamala and halt eel traveled to the
dense forests of the american pacific
northwest
on the trail of the olympia archive i'll
fight bigfoot the last known location of
jarvis
this is another example of a hero
mission showcasing hulk's distress
later you'll take the quinjet to a
remote mode for a while
to uncover shield secrets hidden deep
underground
we chose these missions for the beta
because they feature a diverse
mix of locales from wide open spaces for
you to balance
disney man underground diversity with
high-tech security at sub
let's just say smashable
you play including a showdown with
abomination
what you got there oh [ __ ] you should
test
everything that you've learned so far it
was really important for us to create a
data with a variety of experiences
that show off the epic scale of the game
gosh
go on blonsky so these missions give you
a look into the world of our story
and our characters oh she's a young
kamala khan stepping up against aim
to reassemble earth's mightiest heroes
when the world needs them the most
hell yeah [ __ ] sharp guys homelander
and these hero story missions make for
an already good sized beta
but because marvel's avengers is all
about the team we knew that we needed to
give you
even more than that once you complete
the single player story content
you'll have four different heroes to
choose from to play in some great war
zones and harm rooms that we've
handpicked for the beta
great war zones man there are great war
zones out there
easily my top five war zones
and that means you don't have to pick
just one you can play them all
as you progress through the beta you are
given access to the helicarrier
jarvis and the war table where you can
play four-player co-op in three
different types of missions
harm rooms war zones
no there's nothing wrong with diversity
at all
just to clarify holographic
augmented reality are we scared to the
hawkeye moment for sure
our virtual training simulators
a hero from there you unlock three harm
challenge rooms to test your teamwork
bring your best hero builds to see if
you have what it takes there's
definitely
all three harm challenge rooms are a
great place to hone your combat skills
both
individually and as a team while anyone
can play the game you'll need to focus
and work together to make it into the
most elite spaces
how many can you and your team complete
you can track your i know me i'm gonna
zones everyone's saying to skip you guys
are you guys are an interesting group
watch this watch let's skip to the
hawkins
stop watching this the gameplay i'm so
i'm not i'm not a hundred percent i'm
still i'm still at that point where like
i'm not 100 sold on this
you could just download the hawkeye one
directly i know
you got this john thank you more table
have you seen the hawkeye one no i
haven't seen it yet either
just type in uh marvel hawkeye trailer
marvel hawkeye
[Music]
oh come on reveal
uh trailer reveal
you got this john i know just be calm
john
just really is the key isn't it all
right here we go we got a reveal trailer
we downloaded minutes long okay they're
a minute and 23 seconds long
c we didn't need to spend 17 minutes
yeah i mean
everyone was like watch the little hawk
oh [ __ ] the hawkeye ones at the very end
hawkeye one takes a while to get to
while they explain information about
this beta that we already kind of know
yeah i was like i'm i wasn't that
interested in checking out the war table
stream but people were like you're in it
like okay it's okay
i mean but seeing abomination though was
pretty sweet i didn't know i see
abomination in there that i'm
pretty excited the abomination look red
all right here we go guys all righty
get ready hold on to your socks we're
going to watch the hawkeye one hockey
train surviving avengers
should we lose the fight ahead of us
they listened to the fans and brought
them in
should everything be lost then know this
[ __ ] up a transformer i'm not quite
samuel l
clowning on that haircut
oh now more people are just going to
cloud his hair i know
it's this thing where it's like where's
hawkeye where's hawk
this is the hawkeye trajectory he's not
an infinity war it was like where's
hawkeye he shows up what's up with
hawkeye's hair and game
there where's hawkeye in avengers the
game he shows up
what does it have here yeah she can't
win
there's a lot of comments in there that
are like what's up with this
in the chat in this actual video we
watch that are like
yo what's up with the hawkeye not having
hair man yeah
but it's cool that there i mean that is
actually in there it didn't feel
complete without having hawkeye in there
yeah and i mean trailer it was
especially if you got black widow in
there and in the age of the mcu you got
to get hawkeye
absolutely i mean looks like he looks
really badass in there i know his ass
looks
really bad well thank you all right so
so far what have we watched we watched
the water boys
watched words on bathroom work on
bathroom walls umbrella academy season
two opening
assassin's creed valhalla a divorce fate
three minutes and the hawkeye reveal
trailer
the longest three minutes of the war
table what do you guys think of
hawkeye's look in that avengers uh war
table video
yeah should we check the stream labs
let's check the stream laps let's check
that and then sergio if you're still in
this chat tell us what uh
give tell us specifically what to type
in for the halo trailer we want to honor
your super chat buddy
sergio okay let's go to 731
our first uh we have back to back for
both of these guys
flev dorin hi guys
my request is psych make sure you search
on youtube
psych ion television it should give you
the right trailer because there are old
and this one will show you the humor but
the show has a lot to offer
great writing awesome cast chemistry and
fun times
i forgot to say thanks for doing this i
know it might be risky but i'd like to
share with you guys some of my faves
even if it's
one minute of it also just to be clear
can i send multiple trailers if they're
on the same respectful
five minute mark sure why not yeah
um now is it the eye of the tiger uh
trailer here what is this a couple
minutes long
or i i i have to be very clear when
you're sending in the request guys
because i googled i i searched on
youtube i uh
psych ion television but i have the
tiger as the first result
so he said it's like a minute long is it
a minute long
okay uh private eyes is the private eyes
commercial
which is a minute long from 10 years ago
if we don't see you in the chat soon
buddy we're we're gonna have to move
forward
because yeah but appreciate but still
appreciate it
how about we just see it let's type in a
psych trailer
okay psych we're gonna watch the
privatized psych commercial
have you seen psych i've never seen
psyched no i've never seen even
i've never seen a glimpse of psych i
don't even know what it looks like
who's in it um i don't know answer me
all the questions
we this this stream has been jonathan
tony
asking each other questions that we
don't know the answers to
oh this one's this one's getting chewed
on by the youtube machine yeah if you
guys send a request into super chats
especially or on stream labs please be
as like
clear on what to type in as possible so
that way we can uh really make sure
psych show trailer i on television
okay let's try that one out
this is what it's like when we're
scouring videos of what to cover for
youtube on a particular day
you finish the boys john i have about a
half hour to go
wait so you're on the last episode but
you haven't finished it
you i distinctly remember you being the
person
when i was like i have trouble watching
tv because it's hard to sit down and
dedicate all that time and then you were
like well why don't you watch it in
broken up chunks like i do i watched a
whole season of this show with little
20-minute snippets over lunch i said
that like forever ago
we were living together and i did that
with you iron fist
that's completely different we've had
this conversation completely different
and i've made sure to have it on a big
ass screen every time
god damn man it's the boys final episode
i have prioritized speed over
ideal watching conditions jesus man i've
that's the only way i get through shows
is if i prioritize all of doom patrol
and umbrella academy i know you're
better
is watch once you are a better person
than i am a better person because of
this
what am i looking up it's like trailer
it's hard to type and and talk here let
me hold your mind
psych show trailer uh yeah
i on tv okay
i get it it's ion yeah not like an eye
on a tv it's an ion like a negative [ __ ]
out
like a negatively charged uh yeah there
we
go there we go oh my god it makes so
much more sense now
search and rescue search and destroy all
right so we're
we're getting a quick load up we're
getting it going we're going to watch
this i'm getting a quick load up
this is the time where you guys should
be asking questions in the chat that we
can just answer super quick yeah i can
answer
to fill in the dead space that are
happening here and yeah dean patrol is
great i
actually lied i haven't finished it i'm
only on seas episode three of season two
but uh this month alone i've watched all
of umbrella academy except for season
two which just came
out today and i've seen uh doom patrol
uh season one duke patrol
is my favorite live-action dc anything
outside of the dark knight i like it
quickly made it up there
i was like almost done with season one
where it's like oh my god i think
i think this is my favorite live action
dc anything
um so yeah if you haven't seen do patrol
please watch it
you'll be doing yourself a favor that's
for sure
and without further ado we have our site
we got it let's watch it let's do it
saturdays on ion television how do you
earn a living
i'm a psychic detective sir i was asking
a serious question
some say sean spencer is a phony that's
not possible
is he really legit yeah of course i'm
here to see my client
just how good is he filthy good so good
it's stupid
his abilities perceptive thank you it's
very flattering
his methods here here here
oops disturbing agreed now what about a
sidekick no yes no yes i'm a psychic
detective he just has a magic eight ball
head
that's baloney this deviant duo
is serious about success wait are they
really psychics or not
right no i think one of them has to be
really no
get caught up in psych saturdays 9 8
central
high on television positively
entertaining oh
snap that looked fun that looked like a
lot of fun i did look i've heard a lot
of praise about that but i was kind of
confused is that an actual
are they actually psychic i think the
one of them
is yeah let's look it up let's see what
the log line of the show is
such it's like a corny but very
endearing
kind of show to me yeah like burn notice
i like burn notice psych a novice sleuth
is hired by the police after he cons
them into thinking he has psychic
powers that's funny
with the assistance of his reluctance
best friend the duo take on a series of
complicated cases
not bad oh my goodness that was funny
that was funny everyone's clearing it up
everyone
most people i've seen it seems like a
lot more people have seen this in this
version yeah
hey well maybe we'll have to give it a
go all right let's move forward mimi
oh no no no erica tuesday arika
please watch it thank you erica i see
you all over our stream right now uh
the teaser and love you kiddos miss you
both
love you too erica oh john
copy and download the links so this is
in sound mind we're going for
oh i can just skip off that show looks
pretty cool yeah i know
looks like finn oh look at that
hi oh i'm excited to see what is this
i think this is a sound mind this is a
video game right
oh i've i've erica was showing me a
little while ago i think it's
involved with the same animation company
who did has been hotel
okay i want to say let me look them up
we don't need to go all there let's just
watch it john all right
we got like a gazillion other things to
react to right now
sound mind here we go
all right in sound mind bibsy pop
vivs
oh no okay
oh
this is a cooking game
here's your jump made me jump
oh it gave you the key that's cool
oh nothing's good i'm wrong
apparently we're watching the wrong
thing john
this is the link we pull out of your
your comments
oh yeah stop this all right john you
[ __ ] it up
i took the whole thing something doesn't
work we blame john when something goes
good
we praise john that's the way this
stream works
teaser weird what's the title of it in
sound mine
yeah let me just look the video up
really quick
all right here's the trailer this is a
minute long in sound mine and sound mind
announcement oh this just came out to
come pick up a week ago
how do we [ __ ] this up all right
all right we're gonna watch the
announcement we got the announcement
trailer i'm sorry
all righty um no erica it's not your
fault
it's it's all john's bloody furies in
the chat yay hey hey
buddy
that's where rocky works they say fear
is just a state of mind
a locked door that traps you inside it
but once you find the key to your terror
fear will no longer exist whoa
what a bunch of [ __ ]
oh sweetie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that looks like visually stunning yeah
it looks very atmospheric
but it had you know like the main
character kind of has this like
john constantine attitude yeah of like
i'm sick of dealing with the kind of
supernatural evil that's out there
so yeah getting like the cool visual
aesthetic which is already
unsettling upon its first appearance but
then going into
uh this personality of a main character
just with that one line that he had in
that trailer that just sounded so badass
really makes it um i feel like you're
getting like a combination of
like lovecraftian psychological horror
mixed in
with a bit of this like sam raimi esque
touch to it
you know this looks like my kind of game
i would love to uh that was pretty sweet
get it
thanks erica get a demo or something
yeah that looks good that was a great
call erica thanks for showing
that to us i appreciate that all right
let's uh
and sound mine guys we gotta get the
answer we gotta get a playstation five
so we can [ __ ] do that [ __ ] i know
we'll just let's split it all right
what's next on here mimi
i believe it is mimi we can't [ __ ] this
up again erica
we'll make it up to you on patreon where
did where mimi's go
all right what's up guys hi mimi my pick
is the hbo i may destroy you tv show
uh let's just type it in hbo i may
destroy you tv show trailer
let's make sure it's the right one
i mean that was a honestly that game
trailer was pretty [ __ ] cool i was
actually thoughts on these surprises
so much i can't stop thinking about it
right now that's [ __ ] sweet
okay
yeah that looks really really awesome
all right
i may destroy you official trailer for
hbo this is coming from mimi m thank you
mm-hmm all right
listen to the sounds and i followed the
beats again all white walls i see all
white walls
i don't know how dead lost my end
[Music]
yeah i see him a bit then i caught the
preacher sleeping with the doctor
listen to her talk make her feel good
[Music]
surround yourself with people who affirm
you
are you gonna miss me don't like this
sort of conversation
are we boyfriend girlfriend could you
say yes
it wouldn't be a conversation
is there a reason why you haven't told
him about the assault he's an italian
drug lord
i'm joking
sometimes it gets a bit much what do you
do when it gets a bit much well sims
yoga painting painting and across
i don't even think i know what andy
cross is
there's so much injustice and my job is
to speak the truth
thank you for what you're doing
i love you too i caught the wave i
caught the wave
i caught the sharks and they swim with
the fishes
your blood pressure yeah you will need
to monitor that yes
back in the room sorry
hbo man that's an hx original i would
gladly watch
very exciting check that out um i mean
like i i
would need to go back and examine it to
catch some of like the finer dialogue
points that allude to like the
like what it's about but um i love just
the vibe of it and yeah like
i couldn't tell if there was some kind
of sci-fi angle on it but um but i don't
think it was a sci-fi angle i felt like
it was more just like a visual
representation of what's going on in the
character's mind
yeah no i mean that i would love to
check it out because it just looks like
it has so many different flavors
to it and it didn't like it's weird i
didn't know what to expect when i saw
the poster
but it is it wasn't exactly this trailer
oh is this show already out
yeah oh damn yeah it started airing i
believe okay so the the log line for
it for uh i may destroy you the question
of sexual consent is contemporary life
and how in the new landscape of dating
and relationships
we make the distinction between
liberation and
exploitation damn that sounds like a
deep ass series
oh yeah it seemed like to have a bit of
not as as like strange and surreal but a
bit of that sorry to bother you
element in there but more focused on
relationships and sexuality
you know wow that was crazy yeah
well the music center awesome too yeah
well they they
have uh they have some tv promos with a
couple little sims jams in them too
and uh if that's any indication yeah
yeah like dealing
with i mean it sounds like it's really
dealing with like sexual assault as well
yeah i mean it seems like it would
probably be pretty heavy it looks like
it's got a dark sense of humor but also
dealing with a lot of very heavy
subjects at the same time
which is a really hard line to find but
uh some it's hbo and i kind of have the
impression they would do a good job at
doing it
you know yeah damn
yeah uh mimi in the chat is saying it
deals with assault yeah
yeah there you go all right so you know
be be prepared going in but yeah i'm
gonna add this to my short list of shows
to check well thank you mimi m
and then we got uh who's next on here
katie anne katie anne hey can you react
to the trailer
as always you're one of the best parts
of our lives love katie and the discord
family
thank you katie ann congrats for your
dual certification i sent you a message
i hope that you like it
the do you like the career pursuit you
got
uh but is this mine hunter i've already
i've already
seen all of mine hunting these videos
i've already seen all of mine hunter
katie anne
katie if you're in the chat send another
one in there uh
tell me another one to make up for
because we've i've already seen all of
mine hunter have you seen mine hunter
i've seen the first season of mine
that was from the one of the seasons
yeah i'm not sure
and then where's our makeup for the halo
trailer oh yeah that's right
i'm trying to i'm trying to get the i'm
trying to make sure i'm not missing that
one either
are you okay john you're just checking
your text messages
sorry katie if you're in the chat i'm
gonna message you right now katie
to make sure you do it but adrian bailey
where are you at hi john and greg just
want to say hello and say i love your
trailer reactions and watching for our
two new years now
i also watch your road toe
greg one question what's your favorite
21st century movie
thanks adrian drive
would that qualify a 21st century movie
yeah
i was trying to see the word that you
did yeah uh drive would be uh did that
come out in 2010
i think i think i would go withdraw
nothing after 2001.
right yeah yeah okay uh favorite movie
of the 21st
century jeeps um
god ask again later i don't know mandy
i'll just throw
yeah i go mandy for now yeah why not
avengers endgame
might as well might as well thanks
adrian bailey for your support and then
we got eric horseman here saying
not feeling too well but i wanted to pop
in and support i'm sorry to hear that
eric i heard you haven't been around the
discord as much
i appreciate your your uh streamlabs
support here right now but yeah
i hope you feel better soon dude thanks
bud hopefully you're at least watching
the stream even if you're not really as
interactive right now
hope to pick you up a tad bit now did we
ever get katie in the chat
now i got katie right here okay cool
perf you
are what they like to call on top of
things
alrighty i message people all around and
make sure
all right so let's see here oh let's go
bring back the uh the super
okay wait a minute there was one
specifically that
there let me let me look on my phone
really quick there's one that i
definitely
was like wanting to check out but i did
oh uh can we check out lovecraft county
sure i haven't seen the trailer for that
i love craft county country i haven't
seen the trailer for that yet
uh there's one that came out a week ago
and then we're gonna don't worry guys
we're gonna go through the cop and i've
seen palm springs mark leach mentioned
in the chat absolutely
i mean no one's asked for it right then
we'll do it then we're gonna get to the
super chats
all right a week ago official training
yeah yeah that one have you seen the
trailer for this i haven't seen it yet
nope
it'd be fun to do a trailers revisit i
see some of you guys in the live stream
we've been mentioning doing like
a revisited for one of these but uh yeah
let's check out let's check this trailer
out
all righty appreciate the support
i know that ninety percent of these are
completely demonetizing the video
so appreciate everyone who's been like
uh super chatting and doing the stream
labs
yeah yeah all right here we go uh we did
project power earlier this week
love crap
[Music]
little boys from the south side chicago
the only tourist to get to do that
this door it's about my father and the
secret birthright that's been kept from
us
you're going after it we're going near
the car
just because they don't want you here
doesn't mean you're not supposed to be
gotta get away this is an invitation
to unmitigated power
there's something here that's trying to
get out
everything was where and as it should be
from god to man
to creature what we're gonna see like
cthulhu or some [ __ ]
you can't win this game
wow
oh [ __ ]
that looks great yeah man i look pretty
cool that was great
i mean i'm still a little bit confused
on what it's entirely about but what i
found
interest is i don't think it's based on
like hp lovecraft which is what i
assumed it was going to be based on i
heard it was based on something
different um
jeff lovecraft uh young
okay so go to its wikipedia page okay
um a young african-american travels
across the us in 1950s in search of his
missing father
see like what's interest that looks
[ __ ] incredible
what's interesting to me about th like
it's definitely got some love crafty and
horror to it though
it's based on a novel okay a novel of
the same name
um which is exploration the conjunction
between the horror fiction of
hp lovecraft and racism in the uni
that's so fascinating to me because
a red shadow over insmith uh h.b
lovecraft's one
actual novel and then you come to find
out that like there's so much racism
allegories and hp lovecraft was just
like
major racist and yet his work is so
influential and the racist themes are
like
all over his work in so many ways like
interracial breeding was a big part of
uh shadow over in smith it was a i think
i didn't even pick up on that
i was like ooh we were fish creatures
then i was like oh this is actually a
strange allegory for racism um and
um but and then to see this trailer and
like
flip it on its head and have these
characters who are actually people of
color in here i think it's pretty sweet
to do yeah to have like the lovecraft
title and be like oh but we're gonna be
promoting people of color [ __ ] yeah
that's pretty sweet old hp's spinning in
his brain
i'm definitely watching that show hbo is
so [ __ ] reliable
hbo but yeah uh we'll do a trailer visit
at some point
uh all right hbo at some point today
probably
and sergio have you gotten back to me
yet about what to do love craft is over
party
let's cancel let's cancel lovecraft
cancel hp lovecraft
all right guys i'm gonna throw this to
you i got katie ann to message me back
to make up for the trailer wasn't able
to do
hellblade swanna sacrifice or eve
or evil within two which one do you
think we should watch hellblades
sanawas sacrifice or evil within two
let us know in the comments thank you
katie ann
anyway so john let's go back to here we
are
all right have you guys watched aussie
man reviews i love his commentary watch
aussie man destination volume 12.
i have never seen an aussie man we're
gonna have to look at actually searching
here on my phone to see
aussie man
all right let's watch this alrighty here
we go thanks mark leach
oh goodness gracious man sylvester yeah
we'll watch your infinity saga might you
tribute all righty
get ready okay so yeah okay everyone's
saying hellblade
all right so sergio yeah which
uh which which one uh he was saying he
was saying for halo right
so sergio you got you gotta tell us
specifically which halo one you wanted
us to watch yeah which one for infinite
because there's a bunch
all right ozzy this is from mark leach
interesting reaction catch up here let's
do it
welcome back right now there's only one
destination in the world
accepting holiday makers that's right
we're traveling to the paradise of payne
ladies and gents
someone has flooded their house this guy
is escaping
and he does it in style i don't know why
he couldn't take the staircase
i guess he thought it would look cooler
doing a trick during an emergency
and it did in comes a fast bowl this is
like
slowly watching a plane crash you see
the plane you see the mountain
you see the end result of destination
[ __ ]
here's a truck on fire yeah nah no
further commentary required
it's our curiosity that makes us human
it's also our curiosity that causes us
to go missing
destination atlantis mode activated
maybe he's teleporting and he's going to
fly out of this block
wait for it
coming out of that it looks like a
lovely
mild day to shoot some hoops oh bugger
oh
he's stuck on a pole that's okay he can
use his shoe to knock it down no this is
a very obvious go-to
idea
and the ball you can do it mate come on
both shoes back in action
now get the ball back one shoe and then
two shoes
this looks good the ball is down but
he's only got one shoe again
concentrate okay
meanwhile over at the scooter
competition massive hang time should we
secure this metal pole waterfall
why said the hotel owner no one's dumb
enough to walk on it
yeah they are idiots are like cancer you
should always think from a prevention
first
perspective here's a sheila in a bikini
on a rope swing
yeah nah no further commentary required
that was a great dinner fresh food good
stuff we should come back next week
oh let's go back right now yeah
hamster wheels should be for hamsters we
have treadmills foot pads and parts to
run in
we don't need hamster wheels
he loves it the masochistic bastard
society should always
be reminded to respect elders it's
fantastic when it's elders themselves oh
no what are the ones to remind us
look at the precision and accuracy of
ground he's one
he knows when to walk away the younger
is trying to remember what day it is
the month is destination and the day is
[ __ ]
the old fella is off to do a crossword
anyway watching all of these fail videos
has made me hungry
that looks like a delicious egg a little
too much pepper on it
so you do want to sort that out
it's a good vacuum let's get back into
it that was so
funny
oh damn that was so funny
it was so funny that was great yeah
thanks for watching that that was so
[ __ ] funny
that was a delight christ oh my god
uh my life thank you for saying that man
my laughing gear hurts
there's such a wide variety of like
painful moments and some hilarious ass
moments too
all right johnny oh my god oh
thank you guys have sent in some great
requests so far all right what was it
i love that we're getting such a wide
variety of like old [ __ ]
brand new [ __ ] and just like random
stuff
um hellblade that's just spelling right
there
there it is right there yeah we're gonna
watch hellblade
someone brought it up how to pronounce
it earlier someone said i was
sending us sex two years old sacrifice
wait a minute no it's gotta be short
it's gotta be like a type in trailer
yeah let's watch a such a 45 minute
walkthrough video
305 xbox one trailer all right
we haven't seen this one yet
ooh blood and gore sex and violence hell
yeah that's what i'm talking about i
love all those things
in equal amounts dude whipster in the
livestream has brought up the world
trade center teaser trailer of
spider-man
i want to take you on a roll the coaster
yeah i remember that [ __ ] we're seeing
that in the theaters
what is this oh this is amazing
all right all right hellblade so now
there's got to be a wait
okay can you type can you go to the type
uh go to our chat somewhere
i'm just gonna type in whatever it is
that we're reacting to so that way
anyone who like hops in here
knows what the [ __ ] is up am i spelling
this right john
kind of revenge i should just put in
like
or sacrifice yeah all right there we go
all right let's do this all right here
we go
from anne i
have never i don't know this game
dude you guys
[Music]
this is what happens when you listen to
the voices
the dark rot will grow and soon it will
take us off
[Music]
[Music]
the darkness
you should become a warrior you know
an endless suffering worse than death
and you wanted to surrender this game
doesn't look fun at
what the all is this look it in the eye
and you will go to work
wow
holy [ __ ]
this is like so beautiful i know
she does have a lightsaber yeah jerry
has anyone in the chat actually played
this game
i want to that's so weird to say like
exactly so i was gonna put that and see
william in the chat
said i don't know about a game everyone
should play exactly that
looks [ __ ] like a terrible experience
i feel like it's just such a nightmare
of an experience
i don't know i mean maybe at the end of
it all it's quite beautiful you never
know
she hears voices some of ghosts others
are alters in her mind
yeah that just sounded like just a
terrible psychologically
tormenting mood and then the fact to get
no no actual like
you know um what you're gonna call it
no real gameplay in that trailer just
made it look like where's the fun to be
had here
where's the where's the game fun the fun
of playing a [ __ ] video game
i suppose but like the the mythological
element to it
and uh the haunting harrowing experience
of it just like god damn gorgeous
yeah does anyone in this chat played
that game that's i've never even heard
of this game before
sound that was beautiful that was
absolutely
horrifically beautiful man and
i was like that and horizon zero dawn
are the best game trailers i've seen all
year
oh yeah that's not even from this year
that was incredible um
hellblade a couple of years ago damn and
yeah i mean
it came out a couple years ago these
trailers they don't even have that many
views for a game trailer i'm so
surprised
it's like in the actual xbox and
playstation one thanks for sharing that
katie
that was amazing yeah much aprice
sorry i'm just getting this cut back up
look all right i'm gonna find the halo
one while you
john what do you say he just uh and he
is actually the next one
sylvester fry's in junior can you guys
react to sergio no
sorry sergio sylvester sergio i get
confused but he said he left a super
chat with instructions
so i'm looking for that right now
but yeah sergio there we go step
inside trailer i told you i already saw
the gameplay trailer
uh i did the mic wasn't on so i wouldn't
be reacting
i really yep it's all this so we'll do
the step inside trailer for you today
buddy
all right because i did mention in a
video earlier this week
that uh i hadn't uh we're not skipping
for him it was
he had this super chat earlier yeah he
he's
earlier that we were not able to fill
so this is a twofer this is a two for
one all right
there we go all right yeah i mentioned
in a video earlier this week that i had
a situation where i filmed
this is hap this hasn't happened in such
a long time
but this can happen occasionally we
we have a a shotgun mic that plugs into
the camera that we're looking at us from
right now
and then what ends up happening is
sometimes the mic comes a little
unplugged and when you unplug it a
little bit
you don't get any mic from the from the
shotgun mic nor the camera mic
it's like blocking off all audio ability
to receive anything and so i shot the
halo gameplay trailer
did a review for it come to find out
wasn't recording any audio the entire
time after mike testing it so i'm sorry
man like uh i
don't know why otherwise i just yeah but
hey we can we can at least check out the
halo infinite step inside trailer
honestly i wasn't sure why everyone's
hating on the infinite gameplay trailer
everyone was like really hating on it
and i'm like i don't know i
i don't see the what's so bad about it
alright so john let's do it
[Music]
shotgun mic not an actual shotgun
i haven't seen this one
this is another ps5 like this xbox
john's halo jesus christ
i know what it looks like the ps4
dc marvel love it like both yeah
gameplay demo
sergio the mjolnir exosuit is now
complete
[Music]
even though this technology will save
humanity in the war to come
[Music]
i must remind myself
liquid crystal cannot rise on its own
titanium alloy cannot prevail in the
face of extinction
armor cannot help
until you step inside
it's not the size that matters mate it's
how you use it
so is this going to be like vr this is
going to be first person or something
i'm not sure what the halo step inside
means i thought it was just getting you
excited again
to play as master chief i thought that's
all i was telling you it was like yeah
we got master chief with some [ __ ] and
armor this time around
and you know granted you into the world
but you're not actually getting uh but i
i didn't i don't think it's vr that
would be pretty awesome if it is though
yeah well thanks man appreciate it yeah
why sound off in the comments why why
are people be hating on the new halo
why why you upset i haven't seen the
gameplay trailer so i can't judge it
but uh sylvester fries in june gonna be
the one right there it's gotta be the
one
all right guys we're gonna watch some
more avengers [ __ ] here
yeah thank you sylvester glad we could
get that sorted out
woo sylvester fry's and junior
some quick research on that halo step
inside i want to know a little bit more
about that
well feel free to sound off too in the
comments too sergio too
yeah tell us why you hate halo infinite
okay i'm having trouble downloading this
we can now react to porn we can't we
can't react to porn
last time we tried doing that my
girlfriend walked in and i was like it's
just the thing john and i do in between
filming sometimes i'm sorry it's just a
primer it's really embarrassing
it's just a buffer
okay if he was able to get this up so is
this from sylvester's channel
yeah that must mean you got music in
here my dude
i think he's got music in there that's
preventing it from being
from from making it here let me hold
this
no sergey i'm not saying you hate halo
infant i'm saying they're like people
who are
like really bagging on the [ __ ] uh uh
halo infinite gameplay trailer
you got this john we're trying to
download your video but
i think you have a song in here
sylvester that's keeping it from being
yeah able for us to download so i'm not
sure how you got it
youtube has made it a lot harder to
download things with
music with uh yeah copyright music
especially
yeah we're trying right now we're trying
to download it otherwise we won't be
able to show it
unless we put it over here then we can
just look to the opposite side of the
screen
i mean we can probably get a very low
resolution version of it without having
to take whatever we can right now
without having to do an export um
you got some good views on this man is
there an infinity saga
my like deals with like related to my
hero academia
i'm not 100 certain if we can download
it we will find out
sorry download link was not found um
well we may be experiencing some
technical difficulties with this
particular video although here let me
see i might be able to loophole this
um window capture
and the source i thought i saw the
gameplay demo isn't that what i saw
already
uh i'm talking to sergio right now okay
gameplay demo i'm trying to sorry guys
we're just trying to make sure we can
get this video up here for you guys
let's capture the display
on the right side yeah i was just going
to give it a big explanation
uh yeah i mean the is the camp
is okay sergio in the chat is the is the
halo infinite campaign gameplay
and the gameplay demo are they different
things because the gameplay demo is the
eight minutes something one that i
watched already
not for halo infinite you gotta be more
clear buddy
we're trying to try to manage whoa john
what you got going on there i am
making it so that we can watch this
we'll have to move on and make this
a little bit different we'll have to
make it up to you in some other way so
uh sylvester send us a different one
that we could possibly be able to
download hold on
there we go uh we might be able to play
it this way
unless uh sergio tell us what to type in
specifically well we can we can do it
like this
if we just change the size of this here
oh
john you figured it out yeah let's uh
let's see what happens
um let's do it this is going to be a
little bit of an experiment
but uh we'll see should work yeah
all right so what we're watching right
now the infinite
infinity saga might you tribute
[Music]
way to go john what you saved the day
i'm doing what i can
you see a benedict cumberbatch video
that was so cool
to bring together
hmm
are you ready to start us again uh
i can build an audio capture device
really quick
super easy way to do this john just keep
them entertained okay i got i know what
to do guys don't worry
because then couldn't we just take the
you just gotta take the link right
no i couldn't download the link i tried
several times
so we can we can turn this mic on and
plug some more
unfortunately to get you're saying they
just there's
they can't hear it because of the
they're saying the sound is super low
yeah i don't have an audio input you
know what we can do uh let's try it this
way let's try this um
let's jump back in
uh we're starting this again we're gonna
we're gonna pull this off guys
[Music]
there was an idea
to bring together a group of remarkable
people
i don't know this song
see if we could become something more
so when they needed us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
family you become the hero
that she already thinks you are
you lost a part of ourselves this is
wonderfully edited dude
this is beautifully edited this is
beautifully edited
this is the fight of our lives
this is like uh i feel like i've heard
this song
somewhere heroes
sounds like an anime
[Music]
dude good timing
[Music]
wow
where's the avenger you can bust arms to
its own david
[Music]
this took a lot of work to put this this
is [ __ ] hard [ __ ] to edit man
[Music]
together
this is from my hero academia isn't it
[Music]
that's what maybe people are saying
uh i don't know i've been looking at the
video here
[Music]
well i'll go through the comments
laughter but i i think this is my hero
academia
[Music]
this is so beautifully edited this is so
beautifully edited
we must find our way
[Music]
your timing is great dude it's great
great [ __ ] timing
i think there's like a little bit of
every movie in here of all of them
yeah take that all for one
[Music]
oh yeah nice
that was great that was amazing dude it
was very well done
that was amazing
that was so beautiful and touching uh
well done congrats
dude cancel this before place
let me do uh real quick where you at
yeah buddy hit and subscribe
just subscribe that was great dude that
was [ __ ] great
i don't i mean like to do one for mcu
because i've done like my own kind of
edits before as a hobby to do one for
mcu just seems so daunting like the
editors out there who go out there and
[ __ ] do something like that
is you got a source from so many
different
scenes and try to make sure that you're
editing and timing is down as the right
clip that's matching with the lyrics and
the mood the emotion you got to think
about the build up to it it's obvious
that you had a landing point with thanos
and iron man but then to have to
do all the other clips in between it's
like you gotta first you gotta really
map the [ __ ] out of that
that was very impressive dude yeah
seriously well done
and and great pairing with the song too
um sergio
is saying that uh we did not
he also because he sent in two super
chats for it
he was saying halo infinite gameplay
demo
was the one got you okay yeah this one
there we go
all right all right so you can download
that one but yeah that was that was
amazing guys subscribe to subscribe to
his channel as soon as you can
because that was well worth it thank you
thank you so much for submitting that
man
i was so touched by that and that was my
hero academia right guys
was that my hero academia
i was like watching it going you might
it sounds like
some anime i think
[Laughter]